We have a voicemail number. That
number is two one nine two David P..
Here is a really interesting question, and I do
actually have a lot to say about it. And there's
actually a lot going on in the progressive media
space with this tape. Take a listen to this. OK.
Hey, David, this is just north of Texas. I know
you've been doing some, like, prepping over the
last several months. And I'm wondering what sort
of preparation preparations you're making for
the election just in case things go
south after work. Have a good day.
Well, listen, I don't want to say too much,
but the truth is that I and there are other
progressive hosts who not not just because of
the election upcoming and fears of violence, but
there this might I'm not going to mention
anybody. I don't want to blow up anybody's spot.
There are multiple progressive hosts I know
who publicly live in one part of the country,
but they don't actually live there.
They actually their lives are actually
somewhere else. And they're doing it specifically
because of some of the fears of violence.
All I will say is certainly. The situation
post-election, regardless of the results,
it could get very, very ugly. I at this point
have multiple duplicate studios. They they look
the same. OK. You can't tell from looking where
which studio. I mean, I've actually come to you
from a variety of locations over the last couple
of months. And there is contingency planning
going on. I mean, I guess it's not I don't I don't
think anybody would would find it crazy, given the
circumstances to say that now from the standpoint
of my basic prepping corona virus prepping.
You know, I've gotten the basic things my my cars
now have, you know, first aid kits and changes of
clothes and basic survival elements, as the case
may be. I've got water storage going. We had a
brown water incident at my place a few months ago
where I had to boil water for like a period of six
hours. I'm storing water now. I've got water ready
to go. It's a beautiful thing, but I don't have,
like, years of food. I'm not I've not become
Mormon, you know, I don't have years of food
storage or anything like that. But certainly a lot
of interesting conversations happening within the
independent progressive media space over the last
period of time. I will say to quote Donald Trump,
we have a great bonus show for you today.
We are going to talk about the number of people
that have already voted this year compared to last
election. It is crazy, the difference. Number two,
we will talk about the Michigan domestic terror
plot, which has really sent shockwaves both
through the militia world and through the
world of people who want peace in our country.
And we will also talk about how solar now,
when you actually back out the way that
fossil fuels are subsidized, solar is becoming
the cheapest electricity on the planet. And we
will talk about that and more on today's bonus
show. Get instant access by becoming a member.
Join Pacman. Dot com is the place to do it.
We have a coupon code 20/20 now,
which will save you 66 percent if you so
choose. I will see you on the bonus show.